the trailer looked great and I I uh it
worked on me I want to see Michael
Robbie and hot outfits I want to see
Ryan Gosling in hot outfits I never
heard you sound so straight
[Music]
be honest Nick you can watch the new
Barbie movie I you know what I saw it I
saw the trailer for it
and I got excited that I want to watch
it I like Barbie I didn't know what it
was gonna be about and I was like what
the [__] is the Barbie movie but what's
the premise Margot Robbie is hot they
find out that they're like um
yeah they're dolls they're gonna go to
the real world oh it's like an
existential yeah yeah so it's kind of
cool but like if there's a lot of the
trailer looked great and I I I uh it
worked on me I want to see Michael
Robbie in hot outfits
I want to see Ryan Gosling in hot
outfits I never heard you sound so
straight
seems a little manufactured are you
being paid
well Are You Gonna Save Anthony Lee I
for sure am because Nina's been talking
about it forever she's like you're gonna
go watch with me my lady want to go
watch why does she want to watch it
because they girls like Barbie right but
I thought like the bar move I don't know
maybe I'm ignorant but it seems like
this is for kids
because I think it I think it has to be
a little right it's a little for kids
but I think so I'm like why would grown
women want to watch it because it's
nostalgic
but Ninja Turtle
we're all watching that gig the only
dudes are nostalgic chicks don't give a
[__] about that
girls are not nostalgic like if we if
bye like the mall and you see a giant
Nerf gun oh my [__] God that's crazy
right girls I don't think they would
freak out over [__] I don't know
giant skip it in the middle of Applause
skip this because that's what girls want
to play with no dude it's the it's like
uh like hello like Hello Kitty the
following behind Hello Kitty is you have
like grown ass women following for Hello
Kitty is a little bit bigger than Nerf
guns bro no one's being a fan over skip
it
I I like it was tight if I did see a
skip it I would get nostalgic but check
if there's a skip it [__] movie
Reddit thread
my drawers right now
I have at least three ninja turtle
things at least right Geo who played
with Barbies as a kid has zero Barbie
[__] does he don't have any Barbie [__]
no she has no Barbie [__] the spinach is
not nostalgic that's what I'm talking
about and even less skippits does tip
have any Barbie [__] no no see like
girls aren't as nostalgic with like toys
as dudes are maybe she just wants to see
Ryan Goss in his abs or some [__] I
don't know nah she don't want to say she
don't want to see that that's what she
says she said that's true because the
only kind of girls that do do that are
the new like geeky anime like cosplay
like those girls are into that dude
doesn't want to see the Barbie movie I
don't think so Geo don't play with
Barbie she don't have anything from her
childhood
bro could you imagine Geo as a kid
playing with Barbies she was probably
playing with Skippers I bet she didn't
play with no I I just I don't see oh you
know what you're all right I rarely see
chicks have [__] as an adult that they
had as a kid or you know what a lot of
guys do once they have enough money and
they grow up they buy the things they
couldn't get like you got a DeLorean
right like girls don't do that think
about the when when girls were playing
with Barbies and stuff back then what
were they really playing with themselves
oh they were like doing their hair they
were buying clothes they still do that
[__] too yeah that's true that's whereas
us we were trying to fight crime and
[__] like that with our [__]
imaginations but we ain't doing that
[__] it's not nostalgic so I'm like what
makes them want to watch the movie
because the whole time they were playing
with the dolls it was the movie yeah in
their minds yeah that's true and now
it's manifesting into the screen I think
that's true because the big thing about
Barbie is not necessarily the Barbie
dolls but is the ability to play dress
up with it right I think that's the big
thing of it and I feel like my lady
also she plays dress up bro she is the
Barbie now she's the Barbie you don't
need a Barbie when you become the Barbie
you know the other day she's been on
this kick of buying Coral [__] like
like earrings or some [__] and the
seashells seashell earrings and then she
was looking at it on eBay and I was
looking at her like shopping and I was
like how many pairs of seashell earrings
you got she's like five and I was like I
so why are you shopping for more
seashell here dude you're trying to get
kicked out of the house bro yeah it was
just a playful banter you can't ask
rational questions
but it's just playful banter at that
point but yeah no really though the
girls they are Barbie they live that
life that's why they're probably wanting
to watch the movie for more like life
inspiration yeah you know what I mean
because they're also seeing that come to
life there hasn't been a live-action
Barbie movie right no ever no ever
so I don't know she got me though she's
like she's like you want to watch it I
was like I mean if you really want me to
watch I'll watch she's like but you know
Margot Robbie's in it and I was like you
right she's trying to use that as
leverage for you she knows it's gonna
work yeah is it gonna work this guy
already just said it he thought he was
kidding no I don't even straight no you
know how me and my friends used to play
with our friends Barbies no put them in
our pants
what are you next with it when you're a
kid you just they live in your pants you
just put it inside and you walk around
with it and it was hilarious and then
and then you you go in the backyard and
you rub the hair in dog [__] and then
you give it to the little sister and
they are really mad and it's so funny
okay it's American style yeah fun I mean
when we're like fourth grade third grade
oh okay now I wasn't a full-grown adult
oh okay yeah
you know you're just exploring the world
yeah but I think the funniest thing was
watching my friend go hey watch you
wanna see something funny and he gets
the Barbies and he calls his sister over
and then he rubs the head in Kaka so
[__] up and he goes here you go and
she goes
oh
and then like I was standing there and I
was oh my god I've never I don't have a
little brother or sister now I know why
my brother bullied me because I never
cried laughing so hard while I felt bad
I didn't know what to do yeah
and then you were just laughing so hard
and I was like that's so bad and I
couldn't I couldn't do it but he told me
he's like just do it so I grabbed
another Barbie and another doll and I
rubbed the poo poo on the head and then
I and I was like couldn't stop laughing
yeah he felt alive huh yeah but I was
like how old is third grade like I don't
know eight eight years old yeah like I
don't know if they pay homage to that in
the Barbie movie
Margot Robbie gets her head stuck
you know you know how like those videos
come out of like this is what I wish I
had a big brother and I'm like no you
[__] don't oh yeah dude no you don't
you have no idea
what's this meme that's going around
about people buying tickets to Barbie
and Oppenheimer at the same time I
honestly think it's the sickest [__]
marketing move for Barbie yeah because
like you wouldn't again unless it's like
a anomaly and a truly a phenomenal movie
which it totally could be but like at
the end of the day you already know that
Oppenheimer by Christopher Nolan with
that [__] star-studdy cast is
guaranteed to be like a box office Mega
hit attempt like it's like for the
record books type [__] but then you put
Barbie in such high contrast on the same
opening day and now everybody talks
about Barbie no matter what Barbie's
marketing though has been so freaking
omnipresent yeah you cannot get away
from it everywhere you look and that's
probably why like all our ladies want to
watch this is yeah because women fall
for marketing really easy they fall for
it all the time have you seen those
[__] shampoo commercials seashell
earrings they're the biggest purchasers
of the world yeah they feel like
Barbie's gonna take so hard you think so
no way tank harder than the flash
because
plus the brand of Barbie is so powerful
they've never done anything like this I
think Will Ferrell's in it yeah I don't
think that brand matches the demo is
what I think I think the brand hits
Barbie's been around since so long so
you can you're gonna hit [__] moms
all the way to Chile how many of those
moms have Barbie pajamas no but how many
of those moms have daughters and if a
daughter wants to watch it the whole
family has to go because the kid can't
go as a minor oftentimes right so you're
getting a demo that's like the family
demo that works with the with the mom
you're hitting Lego Movie demo I think
yeah
because I feel like it's dudes
marketing and strategizing on how they
think women think but I don't think
women think the way dudes do
you know I think for dudes it's like oh
a ninja turtle be so [__] sick and so
let's apply that to women yeah but I
don't think women think that way you
know what I'll say it's very rare my
wife is like like we go see this movie
yeah but everyone's half Little Mermaid
pajamas Little Mermaid pictures
Rock the way dudes dude she don't got a
little more mermaid pajamas but another
time what I was surprised where I was
like oh you want to see that it was when
she was like can we go see a little
mermaid please and I go oh okay I guess
we'll see on that so I think so both
your wives are like we need to go see
and very rarely does she say can we go
to the movies rarely she be falling
asleep on all the movies oh bro I try to
show my white movies exactly she's just
[__] it's also who's in the movie and
the budget of the movie yeah do you know
what the budget is by chance no I mean I
just know that it's a it's like an A
plus movie because if it was live action
yeah and then it was like
current Pamela Anderson million oh [__]
Pamela Anderson yeah I don't think No
One's Gonna they're gonna blow past that
they've had tons of Barbie movies that
are like straight to [__] oh yeah
yeah streaming but nobody's watching
that but this is like it's a moment yeah
nine mil I mean a nine figure is a big
budget Oppenheimer was also a hundred
million dollar budget they're gonna spit
the same money as a Christopher Nolan
movie whoa what's Oppenheimer bro I'm
telling you watch the trailer the
trailer got me for the really okay it
makes me worry about open Timer yeah
right 100 million yeah because they
spent it all on having a real bomb right
they blew it up
we'll see if I am wrong Oppenheimer
looks tight though oh yeah I mean
Christopher I want to see that well when
I saw that trailer I was like whoa this
looks crazy this is Barbie dude for both
actually honestly for both tell you
right now why it's not gonna tank wow
because they already showed that Barbie
bowed their head to China remember
they put a map in the movie that was uh
the China version of the division of the
sea yeah so you already know they're
marking it heavily that's actually what
this article is supposed to be about but
we were just having so much fun talking
about Barbie it's how Vietnam is Banning
the Barbie film in Vietnam because of
the disputed map of China South China
Sea claim wow is uh
Barbie I thought popular in China that's
a wild move but it's a normal move I
think that's the thing I don't know it's
very potential okay you know if they
bought it as a kid
oh I don't know the the younger
generation anymore it's just you know
girls always buy adults and Barbies but
that not just American
uh Barbie but they also you know
purchased dolls from other cultures too
so I don't doll culture in general out
there is pretty like unique yeah like
girls be dressing up like dolls and
stuff exactly so I remember growing up
and Japan had its own like Barbie type I
think it was called
um Erica or something like that it
wasn't Kimiko no princess Kimiko come on
but it was like a Japanese girl version
of the Barbie doll oh yeah that's that's
right if I saw some girls in China
collecting those as well yeah yeah but
maybe it was popular I just don't know
but I remember commercials when I was in
Japan at that age watching kids shows
they would play and I was like oh that's
like the Japanese version of Barbie
um
so I don't know how popular Barbie is
outside of the Western countries
I think Barbara's going to do well I
think they're going to smash anything
anything
's A-list will just do well in general
because I have all the the key factors
they're putting books in seats not not
only because of the A-list though it's
just a strong brand like it's crazy
strong and when you see the trick once
again I keep talking about the [__]
trailer but when you see the trailer it
is visually stunning you're like oh I
don't know why yeah it might just be a
fun thing to watch exactly like Spice
World yeah spice well it's kind of tight
though and low-key even I'm guaranteed
gonna go watch Oppenheimer I bet
shunina's gonna fall asleep even while
the bombs gone that movie's dark bro
it's like it's the complete contrast
that's what's funny that's what's funny
about people buying tickets to both yeah
I think you should watch Oppenheimer
first and then cleanse your soul with
Barbie and that's a three hour movie oh
my gosh oh
I saw Oppenheimer you knew that movie
was gonna be [__] three hours dude
the trailer feels like three hours I'm
not gonna watch both
but I don't know okay maybe I I when I
see a lot of bright colors on the screen
I tend to fall asleep I don't know that
makes you fall asleep yeah like when I
see you know Finding Nemo I just I just
oh the bright colors moving yeah I just
like oh I want to sleep you know I can't
stand you're probably gonna feel that
when you watch the Marvel oh yeah yeah
it's for sure yeah
foreign
[Music]